so we're thinking the other day who are
some of our favorite guests well one of
our all-time favorites is the chicken
lady Tara solheim we've had her on a
bunch of times so we decided you know
why not invite her in for an hour-long
conversation on Tucker Carlson today and
we're so glad that we did because she
turns out to be a very cool person we
talked to her not just about chickens by
a whole bunch of things including
alcohol and why she doesn't drink it et
cetera Etc here's part of the
conversation
[Music]
in a world where everyone drinks
casually why do you not drink you know I
know I don't see the good in it it's
expensive
by Satan not doing that we're not going
down that path so I've avoided it and
honestly it's worked out for me and it
works out it does actually it does work
out I completely agree I need it I don't
want it was there ever social pressure
to people always will ask me if they'll
be like oh like why don't you drink and
I'm like oh you know personal reasons
I'm like oh are you Mormon and I'm like
no I'm not Mormon and they're like oh
like you know are you recovered
alcoholic and I'm like no I just don't
want to do it
that's a little off topic for a
political show we'll admit that at the
outset but the chicken lady is great and
we're really glad to interview her and
we think you'll be glad to watch that
interview Fox Nation 7 A.M tomorrow
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight